an enforcer squad take them out
there are moments when all of Mirror's
Edge catalyst components fall into place
moments when intricate level design
allow the fluid freerunning to shine or
the mission at hand delivers a memorable
set piece between those moments there is
a disappointing amount of filler and
several mechanics most notably the
combat that trip up the experience but
these stumbling blocks aren't enough to
completely derail the magic of those
instances where everything goes right
much of that magic stems from the games
of signature mechanic poor core unlike
most first-person action games catalyst
emphasizes movement and momentum over
guns and fisticuffs protagonist faith
Connors moveset consists of vaults rolls
wall runs and more all of which demands
some degree of skill split-second timing
can determine the fluidity of an
animation and successfully chaining
successive moves over great distances
requires serious dexterity skill based
traversal is not only cool conceptually
it's satisfying in practice
thanks to responsive controls
naturalistic animations and the variety
of movement options at your disposal
even little touches like your controller
vibrating right before the impact after
a long drop help make movement even more
exhilarating than it was in the original
game the flip side of this coin however
is the clunky cumbersome combat faith
relies entirely on her feet and fists
when taking down enemies so the game
encourages you to pair your attacks with
her movement skills from maximum impact
when it works it's awesome while running
into a flying kick or sliding into an
enemy's knees and watching his helmet
slam into the ground is super gratifying
problem is many environments are too
open to foster this form of kinetic
combat leaving you to clumsily dodge
around enemies and slowly chip away
their health instead because the enemy
AI is bizarrely predictable I generally
just spammed whatever cheap move I found
most effective against that specific
enemy type thankfully I could often
avoid combat altogether though more than
once I was locked in a relatively sparse
arena and forced to defeat a preset
number of enemies given the game's focus
on movement / fighting these moments
though rare were totally unnecessary the
upgrade system is another low point for
catalyst some essential maneuvers that
should simply be available from the
start like the quick turn and tactical
roll must be unlocked and other
abilities can't be upgraded until you've
progressed far enough into the campaign
this practice of artificially gating
upgrades feels forced and pointless
though thankfully the progression system
ultimately has little impact on the
moment-to-moment gameplay other
important aspects end up feeling a bit
more mixed the most ultimately add more
than they detract the open-world
structure for example results in quite a
bit of empty commuting down familiar
paths as you run from mission mission at
least until you unlock more safe houses
for fast travel outside of the campaign
however the world becomes an enticing
playground full of collectibles to
uncover and races to run several of the
side missions end up feeling just as
substantial as the story missions but
even just figuring out how to scale the
building for no reason can be rewarding
in its own right
you can also craft and publish your own
time trial events by dropping markers in
the environment it's a simple yet
ingenious system and a serious boon for
the game's longevity as for the campaign
some missions feel routine and
unimaginative sending you on simple
errands to areas you've already seen but
others deliver truly pulse-pounding
tension or thoughtful environmental
puzzle solving you'll zipline from the
tops of buildings dive over security
lasers and escape from more than one
collapsing construction site later
levels up the difficulty by adding more
enemies rather than crafting more
elaborate environments to test your
parkour skills and while that's damn
disappointing the campaign still
provided several welcomed challenges and
unforgettable moments the story
stringing it all together is
unremarkable but also unobtrusive it
disappointingly squanders the intriguing
near future dystopian premise by
focusing on a half-baked corporate
conspiracy filled with predictable
twists and paper-thin characters but the
dialogue cringe factor is low and the
narrative lends a discernible arc to the
action it does exactly enough to move
the game along without leaving a lasting
impression positive or negative what is
that art faith art yeah coulda fooled me
funny did you just come here to crush my
self-esteem are you up for some actual
work finally it's worth noting many of
the technical shortcomings that plagued
the beta have been remedied the
framerate dipped once or twice and I
experienced a small handful of glitches
like multiple audio cues playing
simultaneously but lo times were
completely reasonable and none of the
technical hiccups I experienced actually
impacted the gameplay catalyst may not
be the best looking game out there but
it runs well enough to keep you invested
in the gameplay
and really that's what matters I was
often underwhelmed by the visuals the
story the combat but I was also
consistently wowed by the movement and
everything that came with it and for
that reason I can't wait to keep playing
you